you can disagree with me
but I just find it so weird
the way that people exploit their children on the internet for views
likes followers
money whatever
like I just watched a video of this like maybe 4 year old girl crying like that
a million likes
like a million likes and this girl
I think she had a face paint stuck on her face
could get it off
whatever and like she's like crying right
and I get that it's funny I just
also like why
why are you filming your child likely experiencing something that's like
traumatic to them
like obviously it's frivolous to you because you're an adult and you know
logically yes
this face paint will come off
but this is a child who does not understand that this face paint will come off
cause it's not coming off right now and she is like scared right
and again I know it's a frivolous thing and I know it's funny as an adult
but like I just
I don't know like
I remember growing up and being a child
and being laughed at by adults when I was upset about something or whatever
and like
that never felt good right
like I don't
so I just don't understand what the point is of like
making fun of your child and then not only doing that
like posting it to the internet
I get but you know
I'm not I'm not a mother
so maybe you guys have different feelings
but it just I don't know
makes me feel icky right
like filming your child and posting to the internet is already weird to me
I don't think that children's faces should be on the internet frankly
cause there's a lot of freaks and weirdos on here
but using like getting a video of your child crying for likes
not for me sorry